vanessa hudgens just totally cringed
while taking a stroll down memory lane
on sunday the 32 year old actress's hair
stylist and friend chad wood posted this
hilarious video of vanessa doing a
little karaoke
the song of choice vanessa's 2008 track
sneaker night
but it turns out it wasn't her idea to
do a throwback performance
a lot of fun
chad captioned the clip quote don't kill
me for making you sing this
honestly vanessa may not have been
feeling it
but she still got it it's a different
take on it now this isn't the first time
she's revisited an oldie
we're breaking free
[Music]
back in 2019 vanessa dusted off her high
school musical skills for a karaoke
rendition of breaking free
[Music]
the former disney star shared the
musical moment on instagram quote um
here's a really bad aggressive and
totally sober version of breaking free
adding yep that happened lol it hurts my
ears but also makes me laugh
so sure vanessa is down for a little
nostalgia but would she ever be down to
reprise her role as gabriela
[Music]
e.t caught up with the tick tick boom
star last month and she weighed in
it was such a beautiful moment in time
that so many people do hold so close and
near and dear to their hearts
that i don't know it's scary to mess
with something like that because it is
so beloved you know okay so it looks
like high school musical fans shouldn't
hold their breath but they can enjoy
vanessa in princess switch 3 the latest
in the netflix holiday rom-com trilogy
which she produced and starred in
minions fetch me my champagne
i feel very proud of it it was like a
little nugget that started from my love
of the parent trap and now
we are on the third and it feels like a
really really special accomplishment and
off camera vanessa's relationship with
boyfriend mlb star cole tucker seems to
be heating up the two made their red
carpet debut back in november and she
couldn't help but gush to et about her
leading man i've come to a lot of games
way more than i have
in my entire life condensed into a year
um and
and it's so fun like i love going and
supporting and cheering him on but
for the premiere days he's like it's
game day babe
he's like it's so nice i get to come to
your game and i'm like it's yes
same thing um but it's great he's
amazing it's just easy uh we're like the
same person
very much the same person but with
different interests so it's cool
[Music]
[Music]